[Music]
in 2019 Steven Wilson founder of the
high-performing to send charter school
network wrote that efforts to make
schools more equitable and inclusive
could wind up morphing into lowered
expectations Wilson wrote that the civil
rights community had sometimes erred in
allowing rigor to be seen as racist and
argued that intellectual joy is good for
all students of every race and
background astonishingly Wilson's lofty
sentiments were labeled as white
supremacist rhetoric by an online
petition a galling accusation given
Wilson's lifetime of work expanding
educational opportunity yet in response
to the petition ascend fired Wilson the
charter school community responded with
silence the whole episode raises
questions about whether charter schools
will choose group thing over bedrock
educational principles for a sector that
has been defined by bold innovative
leadership the answer will prove telling
do you think groupthink is becoming a
problem in American education let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI